after losing the presidency and
control of the senate the
republican party has introduced 389 new
measures in 48 states that would affect
access to the vote the new proposals
try, for example, to limit access to
voting by mail according to the republicans
the goal is to protect the integrity of the
electoral process but the
Democratic Party says that the measures
introduced by the Republicans
simply make access
to the vote more difficult something that especially
impacts minorities and low-
income people that is why the Democrats
and President Bailén support a
federal bill  that they say would
ensure access to voting for all
with measures that include
allowing people to register to
vote on the same day as an election and
also expanding access to voting by
mail this bill does not have the support
of any Republicans in Congress and
the  Democrats want to pass it with
support only from their own party
something that  What would be possible if the senate
eliminates a process known as the
filibuster which requires
these senators a vote instead of a simple
majority to pass a new law the
challenge for democrats is that a
senator from their own party senator
joe manchin announced with  an
opinion page in a newspaper that he is
against the democrats plan and it is
impossible to implement it without his support
reporting in washington
alexandra limon